you are the change that you want to see
the show it it doesn't necessarily give
you a straight answer of how to fix it
because there's no true way to fix this
racism in the race issues in America but
it does say do something do what you can
Oh
he's visiting his auntie Kim and she is
a law professor and basically throughout
the course of the show of course Michael
Browns incident and the Ferguson
protests happened and it basically goes
through where I fit in in the protests
and how my family relation is changed
we want the police offer to serve and
protect us in the black brown and poor
white community like they do in the
Richard surber that they begin to
clearly understand the need for the type
of unity and the type of understanding
that is needed so that the young people
would not have to keep building because
hopefully they will not continue these
shot folks in the US and around the
world have watched Ferguson Missouri in
shock